what's up I'm Robert Kelly I'm Paul
verzi from the bone to pick podcast and
I'm back to answer the internet if you
had the flexibility to blow yourself
would you do it what if everybody uh
knew you did it when you're right to the
fire
I'm gonna set I I already tried this
yeah and I don't you wait wait yeah you
tried yeah I found a little I swear to
God and people can think I'm lying I
found a little how-to uh stick figure
instructional thing to blow yourself oh
you needed that huh you couldn't figure
it out
well I no I couldn't I really couldn't
said you lie down flat uh and then you
go put your legs up over your head and
then wait and then you're gonna go back
a little further and then you'll let
your let your uh let your body weight
sink down into your face
and I almost snapped my neck in my tub
I swear to God I I heard a crack and I'm
like I had I almost snapped my neck and
I got that close yeah what happened I
was fat I was a little chubby too at the
time this was not this is one of my
facts this was not this is before I was
married but I was with my wife like she
was coming home within the hour
put your fat got in the way like if you
were well what happened is the the
stomachia went back into the yeah so it
was coming out it was coming out and
then it went back in right yeah so it
turtled back in
the phone yeah I had a friend who had
such a big hug he was able to get some
in and he said when he did it he thought
it would be great and he said he felt he
felt weird and he stopped that friend is
Giannis Papas
could you successfully steal a base in
the MLB if you had a hundred attempts I
listen I'm a positive guy I'm a
delusional guy and I'm a guy that thinks
anything is possible he also stealing
bases is like your your I got your trick
right I 100 yes that's right I used to
get drunk he remembers and I would go
out in the yard hammered and I would
steal an imaginary second base and I
would always be called out and I would
argue with a fake um but I I always
thought I made it I would say yes in 100
attempts you [__] up Paul knows
baseball it's not gonna say he could
steal the face I could just out of 100
out of 100 I could get two well here's
the thing
you would you would be able to turn back
to First that ball would get there but
let me ask you a question what happens
if I'm on First and I'm I'm leading and
I see the pictures I see that it's a
what like a hundred attempts means a lot
of things can happen you're you're
banging on a wild pitch or or like
something up high or or it's in the dirt
and I just take off if a ball goes to
the backside yeah maybe and here's the
other thing hold on as that an alien
ship comes down everybody does that if
you run a second you'll be able to do it
oh wait a minute yeah you'll be able to
do that 100 attempts what if it's a bad
throw from the catcher that that happens
like that like a cat because there's a
[__] professional athlete with
professional athletes speed running
not a Greek from best Chester
this guy eats out three nights a week
would you rather be the best looking
dude in the world or be able to read
minds hundred percent best looking dude
in the world I'm already a psychopath I
read your mind anyways I know right now
you're thinking I'm a piece of [__]
you're lucky I put you on the thing and
I like Paul better than you
hahaha
[Laughter]
yeah I wouldn't want to remind just
because I would look at those people
differently like probably somebody you
love like your wife and all of a sudden
you find out what your wife's thinking
so yeah no I would I would definitely I
know but I think about people and stuff
so dude I have OCD I've thought about
like killing people I loved right I have
I have obsessive thoughts like right now
I'm thinking about chopping your head
off and like what if I was just drinking
your blood dude I've been on stage what
the [__] is happening between you two
you guys both need mental health I've
been on stage you thought about feeling
my dick in this person's
dreams and I'm like what if I just
started throwing my so yeah I'll take
the best look which celebrity would you
most want to see in a sex tape oh man ah
I would say I'd want it to be really
funny so probably like you know like
dementia Joe Biden
I don't want to see something I envy
just seen him sniff a girl's tit
mumbling
I mean I wouldn't mind seeing uh like
Elon Musk just his head
no one even thinks about answering a hot
chick who wants to see that I mean
that's not interesting Elon Musk [__]
has got to be a weird like I feel like
he's like robot just like I'm gonna come
in you to have a child and like that's
it nah I bet he's got a flamethrower
cheese to a Tesla it's [__] I'm the
[__] his head gets red from the
T yeah dude about Donald Trump and
Whoopi Goldberg
that would smell there'd be a smell in
the air if you could get shit-faced with
any U.S president who would it be
George Bush
he was the director of the CIA during
the Kennedy assassination so like he
knows like George Bush Senior knows all
of the secrets so having a beer with him
getting him a little tuned up and be
like hey dude dude what happened to
Kenny come on give me one give me aliens
or Kennedy just give me one and he would
be like all right you got both you know
what I mean like that was the time the
director of the CIA in the 60s that dude
who knows he went to his grave with some
[__] dude for real I I mean I'd do
Kennedy yeah oh dude we were smoking
Cubans banging starlets his brother come
in with some I mean
hey what
the Lord my God then we just kill the
girls if they start yapping I mean
that's back when men were men
marry [__] kill Italian food Mexican
food Chinese food I mean I mean come on
all right
food is not the Jordan to you I can't
talk to you anymore I actually probably
agree with you unfortunately but I would
say that I put uh I put Mexican food
above Chinese is one of the most
overrated it's all vegetables it's all
weight they throw vegetables they cut up
carrots they put in rice stop saying
they because you're making with your
accent you make it sound racist you
gotta bring the tone down just a little
brother I know
yeah I would say so uh marry Italian
yeah
uh [__] Mexican Mexican kill Chinese
that's right I mean that's just that's a
tough one time to answer that yeah that
sounds like your politics too by the way
[__]
[__] dirty Republican listen marry
[__] kill I mean Italian food top of
course a marrying Italian food but I
disagree I am a hundred percent first of
all I love Mexican food I love Mexican
people God Bless but I'm just saying
they just roll everything up and put
some [__] on top and eat it Chinese is
sauces and dumplings and and and noodles
and I'm it's very similar to Italian
food so I'm gonna go 100 it's noodles
it's noodles who do you think about you
think Italians came up with noodles what
the [__] did we do with who came up with
noodles it's noodles and broth what
about what we do Chinese Chinese there's
no garlic Chinese are you [__] nuts
chinese-made noodles dude we put we make
money God we make lasagna what do they
have that [__] with that Chinese made
the noodle it's like the Moors the Moors
did with meatballs yeah that's your
[__] that's Chinese
forehead meatballs you don't know your
history I'm going Italian I'm going
Italian I'm going Italian Chinese and
then Mexican at the end would you rather
your girlfriend get a notification every
time you watched porn with the
description or a notification where uh
you are at at all times both pretty bad
that was pretty bad no I I 100 you can
know where I'm at I'm in the bed jerking
off the [__] porn
I don't have a type in Sheridan Hotel
in Sheridan Hotel or chicks with
my cashier I mean I get weird I've been
getting weird dude I had oh I did some I
got into old women like a month ago yeah
dude I'm talking dude we're talking
we're talking with a chick
I swear to gosh you're an owl and he was
like oh sorry like yeah this [__]
bumped her hip out I mean I get because
you get yeah I don't know I get weird a
little bit you know I gotta taste a
little bit you know what I mean I mean I
go back home I go back home to normal
stuff but like wait and she knows where
you are at all times 100 where am I I'm
right next I got a 10 year old I'm
either with her or I'm in the shower
cranking one out you know like
out running like errands I'll be there
like in 15 minutes and it's just you're
actually having a beer at the bar
because you need to get away from it not
like deep lies just like little lies
where you're like no I'm stuck in
traffic you know you're not you know
like all that kind of [__] now 100
percent the my my porn history I don't
want yeah I don't want you knowing I
don't want her knowing anything you know
what Kevin just changed my mind I'm
gonna go with porn because even though
she knows where I am I got a couple of
kids at least if it's a few times point
because I'm not a big porn guy at all
when I do it I can just go well where
are you
you know what I mean like hey I wouldn't
need to right so so I would I'm gonna do
that instead what is your stance on
washing your hands after taking a piss
well I mean here's the thing I
George Collin had the greatest answer
ever it's like you know people you're
washing your hands after you take a piss
it's like my dick is clean I should wash
my dick after I after I take a piss
because my hands are disgusting you know
what I mean it is true but I do I do
wash my hands after I take a piss
dude every time I go to the bathroom I I
dock the scrub
I do because I don't
I don't like [__] I don't like I just
touch my stomach I got piss on my hands
you have a bigger problem if you're
pissing on your hands no no no no no no
no no no how old are you 38 yeah dude
when you're 52 come [__] talk to me
it comes out dude it comes up
longer yeah but then you shake it and
you got to push your stomach up and what
is the garnish to make because it's your
[__] tomatoes
[__] are you what are you doing whatever
I don't have this problem because when I
go to public bathrooms
bathrooms what I don't you have one of
those no I piss on the seat if I go into
because I'm in airports a lot and it's
gross even the people wash their hands
are gross so what I'll do is I take it
down and I let it I I make my I adjust
it and I hold it steady
with the band so the band holds it
steady yeah so that's what you do I use
the elastic sometimes to just hold it
psychotic and it goes in and then all of
a sudden I just lift up and I'll have to
watch that's crazy that's crazy it's
almost it's crazy it's taking like a
little hammock and you're like yeah
Newark Airport packed no what do you
talk washing your hands is it [__] uh
is the most manly thing we do it's the
thing you teach your kids
that is that is a hundred percent who
the you're a dirty person you're a dirty
person listen anybody who's just
comfortable enough to admit it as a guy
will tell you there'll be far more
people not washing their hands than
washing their hands listen I don't
because they're not [__] and they
will admit it on the internet dude when
you take a [__] do you wash your hands
oh my [__] God I mean put a door here
it's green screen put a door I want to
walk through it
I figured out a way not get piss and
[__] all over me because I don't know
you can't when you take a poo there's no
way there's no way you can no [__] that
touches my hands you're out of your mind
no you're right there's [__] Vapors that
[__] hate your knuckles what you
better take a shower then you better
[__] clean your face listen dude why
don't you wash your face is [__] Vapors
even a thing shut up listen
you got it when you take a [__] you have
raise your hand if you think when you
take a [__] you have to wash your hands
when you're done raise it then one two
three
four you're wrong wrong the brothers oh
my God thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out